歡迎收看泛科學新聞
謝謝另外一百位泛糰會員的加入
我們才得以繼續製作這個節目
也謝謝每一位在各個社群媒體上
給予我們鼓勵跟建議的觀眾
我們都認真地觀看
也會持續從中找到改進的方向
如果你希望這個節目能持續下去
希望泛科學繼續製作
各種科學議題剖析
或是延續熱門的
半導體、量子、能源等系列
請務必透過加入會員
來讓我們獲得續航的翅膀
Salamat sa inyong suporta
對不起
和大家報告
目前《科學生》因為發現內容與印刷錯誤
已緊急下架並全力除錯中
我們深感抱歉
同時相當感謝幫忙糾錯的讀者
請再給我們一點時間
修正後會立即重新上架
已經預購或申請贈書的讀者
完全不用擔心
重新上架後
團隊會立刻寄出新版
感謝大家耐心等候
這是古生物學史上最慘烈的
「課金抽卡」翻車現場
先把時間拉回 2021 年的冬天
當時
美國阿拉斯加大學費爾班克斯分校的教授
也是知名的猛瑪象研究者
Matthew Wooller
他看著校內北方博物館地下室
那一千五百塊化石
心裡很苦
雖然這些化石
根據外觀被標記為「猛瑪象」
但因為碳14定年很貴
這些骨頭就這麼躺了幾十年
看起來很老
但沒人知道它們幾歲
就像泛科學的那個阿伯
誒 這稿誰寫的
於是他在 2022 年推出了
「領養猛瑪象」計畫
乍聽很有愛心
但其實就是「轉蛋手遊」
只要課金 350 美元
就能認領一塊骨頭
並獲得幫它測年齡的權利
如果你領養的骨頭測出來是
「史上最年輕的猛瑪象」
就能獲得獎盃、媒體曝光，名留青史
這活動還跟那間想復活長毛象的生技公司
Colossal Biosciences 搞聯動
把腦筋動到了學校頭上
讓小學生也來集資抽卡
好死不死
他們真的抽到了傳說中的大獎
編號 UAMN3760 和 3724
這兩塊椎骨生長板
外觀被鑑定為猛瑪象
但碳14定年
顯示竟然只有兩千到三千年的歷史
這超震撼的啦
因為一般認為猛瑪象一萬三千年前
就從阿拉斯加內陸消失了
雖然海平面上升後
被困在離島的最後一批
活到了 5000 年前
但 2000到3000 年
這這這
要是真的
秦始皇都可以騎猛瑪象了
於是團隊深入檢測
先測骨頭裡的穩定同位素
也就是碳-13跟氮-15的比例
結果更詭異
因為「You are what you eat」
我們的身體在代謝蛋白質時
傾向把比較輕的「瘦子氮-14」尿出去
而把比較重的「胖子氮-15」留在體內
每吃一頓
體內的氮-15就會變濃一點
猛瑪象是吃素的
累積的氮-15應該很少
但這兩塊骨頭的數值
卻跟海獸一樣高得嚇人
這味道
是說謊的味道
事情不對勁
逼得科學家出絕招
古DNA鑑定
而且是粒線體 DNA
因為一個細胞裡只有一套細胞核 DNA
但卻有成千上萬個粒線體
雖然原版食譜燒光了
但這本書助印了幾萬份
撒得到處都是
我們只要找到其中一份殘本
就能確認這傢伙是誰
但一般的 DNA 萃取方法
抓不住碎成渣的短片段
團隊使用了著名的 Dabney protocol
這套方法的操作非常精細
先把骨粉溶解
加入關鍵的「結合緩衝液」
裡面含有高濃度的鹽酸胍(GuHCl) 和異丙醇
這種化學環境會破壞水分子的結構
在高速離心的時候
那些短到只有三十個鹼基長的 DNA 片段
會死死地吸附在二氧化矽濾膜的表面
而其他的雜質則會穿過濾膜
被甩出去
最後再把這些純淨的 DNA 洗下來
丟進定序儀比對
讓它回答 我是誰
答案不是葉舒華
但竟然也不是猛瑪象
而是北太平洋露脊鯨和小鬚鯨
但這不對啊
這兩塊骨頭是在阿拉斯加內陸發現的
距離最近的海岸線有四百公里遠
雖然現代偶爾有鯨魚迷航游進河裡
但這可能性太低
撇除這個科學家還有兩個推測
要嘛是古人類在海邊獵殺了鯨魚
然後費盡千辛萬苦
把骨頭背進山裡
想故意讓 2000多年後的古生物學家覺得困擾
要嘛就是
嗯
博物館自己搞錯了
當年入庫時混到了別箱的樣本
你覺得哪一個解釋最合理呢
不管怎樣領養猛瑪象
對科學研究的貢獻還是很大
也讓更多人得以參與
説到這
身為 YouTuber 當然要宣傳一下
不用 350 美金、不用 350 臺幣
最低 45 元
就可以領養泛科學的
那個阿伯
嗯
我們的細胞膜不只是一層皮
而是奈米級的「自驅動發電機」
因為從物理學角度看
如果細胞膜只是因為熱量而隨機震動
左抖右抖
最後位移是零 產出也是零
大家都是零
對 你也是零
這在熱力學上叫做
「細緻平衡」(Detailed Balance)
意思是在微觀世界裡
每一個正向的過程
都有一個完全抵銷的逆向過程
總能量不增不減都在做白工
但科學家一直懷疑
對 科學家就是一直懷疑
細胞狂燒 ATP 這些能量
真的只是變熱散掉嗎
或許錢錢沒有不見
只是變成了自己喜歡的樣子
美國休士頓大學與羅格斯大學
組成的團隊
決定把答案算出來
根據計算細胞膜上的蛋白質
就像萬事屋裡吃飽了撐著的神樂
消耗 ATP 之後
竟然會不斷地踹細胞膜
研究剛發表在《PNAS Nexus》期刊上
是的 研究團隊不是生物學家
而是來自機械工程系和數學系
專精力學的工程師
他們請出法國物理學大師
保羅·郎之萬 (Paul Langevin)
百年前發明的郎之萬方程式
但團隊對經典公式動手腳
植入了一項有記憶的「主動雜訊」
不像一般熱雜訊瞬間生滅
用來模擬蛋白質在消耗 ATP 時
對膜產生的一種
持續性、有方向的推擠
這次研究沒有勞贖犧牲
他們沒有在顯微鏡下戳真的細胞
而是拿老鼠神經元的電阻數據
混搭酵母菌蛋白質的密度參數
在電腦裡構建通用的「虛擬細胞膜」
接著「撓電效應」(Flexoelectricity) 登場
簡單說
因為我也只能簡單說
把細胞膜
「從禪院直哉掰成禪院彎哉」的時候
因為內外層結構不對稱
電荷會被擠壓分開
瞬間產生電壓
當程式開跑
他們發現這些由蛋白質引發的「主動推擠」
配合膜的彎曲
竟然打破了熱力學的細緻平衡
讓膜兩側直接「抖」出了電荷累積
而不是隨機中和
模擬數據顯示
這種機制能讓膜兩側
累積出高達 90 毫伏 (mV) 的電壓
這可是個「暴力輾壓」級的數字
因為我們知道神經元運作有個閾值
像揍敵客家的大門
推的力道要是不夠
連動都不動
通常電壓需要提升個 15 到 30 毫伏
但研究發現的這 90 毫伏
可是好幾倍
絕對足以把門推開
引發動作電位
而且更扯的是
它還打破了物理學上的
「時間反演對稱性」
強制把離子往同一個方向送
根本不需要額外消耗ATP開通道
光靠回收膜震動的機械能
就能把離子泵進去
一切都發生在毫秒 (ms) 之間
跟神經訊號發射的速度完美同步
但但但
真實的細胞膜並不像模擬裡那麼乾淨
上面擠滿了細胞骨架、膽固醇
環境黏稠得像第一天的動漫展
在那麼擁擠的環境下
膜真的能自由震動發電嗎
因此這項機制
更可能是一個「物理啟動器」
也就是細胞先用「震動」
把門推開一條縫
讓後續的化學離子流
能更輕鬆地把門踹開
無論如何
我們過去一直以為
神經傳導完全靠化學物質
來堆疊濃度梯度
但這研究告訴我們
細胞膜自己也可能物理性地
參與了訊號傳遞
而如果我們能模仿這種機制
開發全新的人造皮膚或仿生晶片
就有機會不需要外接電池
能自我供電跟運算
啊 難怪這群工程師要研究這個
人類的「行星防禦系統」
發現了一個打不死的怪物
還記得 NASA 之前的 DART 任務嗎
拿衛星去撞小行星那個
把它撞歪了 對吧
但這種怪物小行星
你用同樣的方法去撞它
它連抖都不抖
根據維拉·魯賓天文台
與華盛頓大學等聯合團隊
在 《天文物理期刊快報》上
(The Astrophysical Journal Letters)
發表的最新研究
小行星 2025 MN45 就是這個怪物
這顆小行星直徑有 710 公尺
比台北101高 200 公尺
But size doesn’t matter
要命的是它的轉速
不 天文台沒有拍到它旋轉的影片
我們知道它在轉是因為「光變曲線」
由於小行星不是圓的
是像地瓜
或阿姆斯特朗回旋加速噴氣式阿姆斯特朗砲
一樣
長條狀的
當它「寬面」對著我們
反射光多 看起來就亮
轉到「窄面」看起來就暗
魯賓天文台發現這顆光點
根本是爆閃燈
經過計算它每 1.88 分鐘
就完成一次戀愛循環
痾 不是
是「亮暗循環」
代表這顆小行星
轉的跟第三季OP裡的脹相一樣快
這有多誇張
天文學界有張圖表叫
「自轉障礙」(Spin Barrier)
科學家統計了幾萬顆小行星
只要直徑超過 150 公尺
它們的轉速幾乎都會卡在 2.2 小時 這條線
這條線之後
小行星的數量就斷崖式下跌
因此科學家有個簡單的公式
極限自轉週期
P 大約等於 3.3 除以密度的平方根
一般石頭的密度大約是 2 到 3 (g/cm³)
帶進去算
極限就是 2.2 小時
為什麼
因為絕大多數的小行星都是「碎石堆」
靠著微弱的「萬有引力」勉強吸在一起
就跟友情一樣
一旦旋轉產生的「離心力」
大於把石頭吸住的「重力」
整顆小行星就會
轉甲撐袂牢 慢慢散開
（tńg kah thiann-bē-tiâu, bān-bān suàn-khui）
但這顆 2025 MN45
卻比極限轉速快了 70 倍
套進公式會發現
如果要轉這麼快 還不爆開
密度得達到 11,000 (g/cm³)
根本不可能
所以這傢伙絕對不是靠重力吸住的爛石頭
它是一整塊靠著化學鍵
緊緊黏死在一起的「實心巨岩」
科學家推測
它很可能是一顆「遠古原行星」
被撞爛之後
倖存下來的一塊完整岩盤
經過數億年的宇宙碰碰車
外層鬆散的土都被撞飛了
只剩下這塊最硬的骨頭留了下來
這發現可重要了
因為如果類似的小行星往地球衝過來
我們得知道該怎麼辦
而最變態 但也讓人高興的是
這項發現僅僅是魯賓天文台
用了 7 個晚上的測試數據找出來的
這台擁有 32 億畫素的世界最強相機
只是開機試跑了一下
就發現了 1900 顆從未發現過的小行星
其中有 19 顆這種超快自轉體
之前的 DART 任務去撞的小行星
是「碎石堆」
但要是遇到 2025 MN45 這種範馬勇次郎
那就
嗯
魯賓天文台現在做的
就是先幫人類建立詳盡的「怪物圖鑑」
盡量分清楚
誰是軟柿子 誰是硬骨頭
蛤
你說那誰是阿姆斯特朗回旋加速噴氣式
阿姆斯特朗砲
誒 每天盯著螢幕看
是不是覺得眼睛又酸又乾
好像快瞎了
但有一種生物在海裡看了四百年藍光
視力卻超健康
牠是格陵蘭鯊
對 川普很想要牠
住在北極深海 壽命長達 400
長久以來科學家以為牠們是瞎子
畢竟牠們的樣子實在太慘
絕大多數格陵蘭鯊的眼球上
都插著一隻 3 公分長的
粉白色寄生蟲（Ommatokoita elongata）
這東西會把角膜啃得破破爛爛、混濁不堪
看起來就像是台開了幾百年的老爺車
擋風玻璃全碎
還黏著口香糖
但根據美國加州大學爾灣分校
與丹麥哥本哈根大學
發表在 《自然通訊》的最新研究
我們錯了
這台老爺車搭載的
竟然是人類夢寐以求的
「永續視覺系統」
為了幫格陵蘭鯊量視力
研究團隊在 2020 到 2024 年間
直接殺到北極圈內的迪斯科島 (Disko Island)
頂著零下低溫暴雪
拿著格陵蘭政府核發的特許執照
利用科研延繩釣
把鯊魚釣上來
因為眼球樣本極度嬌貴
科學家得在劇烈搖晃的甲板上動手術
麻煩的是
如果要看結構
絕對不能冷凍
不然冰晶會把細胞戳成稀巴爛
如果要分析基因
又絕對不能常溫
因為 RNA 極為脆弱
幾分鐘就會崩解
所以科學家必須現場「分屍」
一組眼球泡進 「4% 多聚甲醛(PFA)」
讓細胞定格
保留視網膜結構
另一組則立刻剝離視網膜
丟進 RNAlater 保存液
然後插進 -20 度的冰櫃以搶救基因
經過這番極限操作取得樣本後
科學家做了三道驗證
第一關是物理檢測
首先要確認
這塊爛掉的擋風玻璃透光嗎
科學家用光譜儀去測那顆
被寄生蟲搞得像白內障的角膜
數據顯示紅光和綠光全被擋住
但在 470 到 480 奈米
也就是深海中
唯一能長距離傳播的藍光波段
透光率仍維持 66% 到 100%
寄生蟲噁心歸噁心
但它「剛好」沒有擋住鯊魚最需要的光
看有！(khuànn-ū)
接著是第二關功能測試
確認光進得去後
科學家要確認
視網膜能不能讀取訊號
切片顯示格陵蘭鯊的視網膜
全是桿狀細胞
沒有分辨顏色的錐狀細胞
團隊接著使用 「異源表達」 技術
把鯊魚的視蛋白基因 (rh1)
植入培養皿裡的
人類胚胎腎細胞 (HEK293S) 裡
等於讓人類細胞
裝上鯊魚的視覺驅動程式
結果這些細胞成功製造出鯊魚的視紫質
經過測試
它對 458 nm 的藍光反應最強烈
證實格陵蘭鯊擁有一套深海特化的
「高感光單色夜視系統」
最後來到第三關
也是最重要的
壽命測試
科學家想問
用了幾百年 零件不會壞嗎
普通生物的視神經細胞
老了就死 死了就沒
團隊對高齡鯊魚的視網膜
進行了 TUNEL 檢測
這是一種專門找「細胞凋亡」的技術
只要 DNA 有斷裂
顯微鏡下就會發亮
結果
顯微鏡下一片漆黑
這表示即便活了幾世紀
牠們的視網膜細胞依然完好如初
RNA 定序更發現
格陵蘭鯊細胞內的 DNA 修復基因 (如 ercc1)
表現量高得離譜
彷彿跟台積電一樣
有一支 24 小時待命的維修小組
只要 DNA 一有裂痕
馬上反轉術式
直到被釣上來
變成2.5條為止
終於
物理學家總算學會
怎麼不讓人造太陽把自己給炸了
根據刊登在《Science Advances》上的
新研究
中國 EAST 團隊
成功讓托卡馬克裝置裡的電漿密度
飆到了理論極限的 1.65 倍
要知道在核融合的世界裡
「密度」不只是數字
它是鈔票 是信仰 是真理
核融合反應產生的能量
跟密度的「平方」成正比
如果能把密度翻倍
得到的能量是四倍
所以幾十年來
物理學家都想把電漿塞得越滿越好
但卻總是撞上
「格林沃德極限 (Greenwald Limit)」
Well 托卡馬克裝置就像是一個
高壓的甜甜圈舞池
裡面的粒子在攝氏一億度的高溫下
跳起
「愛的是非對錯已太多 來到眉飛色舞的場合」
蛤 你說這只有阿伯在聽
fuck
過去的經驗告訴我們
要是太貪心
想塞進去的粒子
超過了格林沃德極限
舞池邊緣的人就會被擠去撞牆
雖然這些牆壁
通常是鎢金屬 (Tungsten)做的
很硬
但脾氣很差
一旦被高能粒子撞到
就會發生「物理濺射」
噴出一堆金屬雜質進去舞池
「混合他的衝動 她的寂寞 不計較後果」
這下糟了
就像誤觸消防灑水系統
這些重金屬原子帶有非常多的電子
會瘋狂吸收周圍的熱量
並以光的形式發散出去
原本一億度嗨爆的電漿
熱能瞬間被這些雜質吸乾
溫度直線跳水
電漿一旦失溫
就會電阻變大、電流亂竄
整個磁場約束失效
高溫電漿像超級布羅利一樣
無法控制 撞壞機器
這就是為什麼過去幾十年
大家不敢越雷池一步
但「理由一百萬個有漏洞
快說破 說破以後最赤裸」
科學家這次打破了極限
研究的核心技術叫做「ECRH 輔助歐姆啟動」
裡面有兩個名詞
第一是「歐姆啟動」
這其實就是國中理化教的 V=IR
利用電流通過電阻會發熱的原理來點火
就像家裡的烤麵包機一樣
但電漿很傲嬌
溫度越高 電阻反而越低
想單靠這招衝高密度
就像在暴風雪中「鑽木取火」來煮開水
效率極低
所以我們需要第二個東西
「ECRH 電子迴旋共振加熱」
這是一把功率高達
600 kW 的微波噴火槍
科學家在鑽木取火（歐姆啟動）的同時
直接開了這把噴火槍（ECRH）
對著電漿轟
除了補足熱量
更重要的是它能精準控制加熱的位置
這種「輔助」改變了電流的分布
讓電漿的「核心」很熱
但「邊緣」卻保持相對冷靜
論文裡把這叫做「電漿-壁自組織」
因為邊緣溫度被控制住了
電漿跟牆壁達成了一種恐怖平衡
牆壁覺得
你唔搞我 我唔搞你
因為沒有雜質進來搗亂
電漿就變得超乾淨
既然電漿乾淨又穩定
科學家就可以大膽繼續塞
密度就這樣一路飆升
突破 1.0 衝到 1.3
最後穩定在 1.65 倍的格林沃德極限
這時電漿進入了傳說中的
「無密度限制區域 (Density-free regime)」
就像明明把 CPU 超頻到了極限
結果風扇反而越轉越慢
溫度還更低
當然啦
這還是實驗室裡的成果
要在發電廠等級裝置上
重現這個奇蹟
還有很多工程問題要解
但至少這打破了我們對「限制」的恐懼
男的 女的 都不要再等候
自由 自由 現在就要自由
中國科學家加油喔
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或是對哪一則新聞想黜臭
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了訂閱、按讚、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼
比格陵蘭鯊還帥的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄
我們下週見